that's why if you remember cog's been on
the record when everybody was like yo
that 12 month format is fun no it's not
fired because the reason why I don't
like it is one you take away the Wonder
and the mic drop moments like solve is
talking about the magic that could
happen right that's what make a Nintendo
yo I can't believe they drop you know
what I'm saying at the end same thing
with the Sony Sleek all men so I I hated
that then you put undue pressure that
these games better come out in the 12
otherwise you're gonna have King out
here doing what king do making this
recognition literally unnecessary
pressure that could have been completely
right away now where King loses me is
games get delayed every day bee like
like like literally you know what I'm
saying so like God of War about Timmy
life I feel that but Timmy died Waiting
for God of War Ragnarok in 2021
so Timmy died waiting for Zelda breath
of the wild two in 2022